donc je représente les citoyens de la
convention qui se sont positionnés
contre l'évolution de la loi et
l'ouverture à l'aide active à mourir
on est un groupe assez important dans le
sein de la Commission dans la convention
pardon et on entend ici non pas défendre
le livrable mais l'expliquer vous avez
entendu des chiffres ces chiffres-là
sont à interpréter et à comprendre
par exemple dans les 75% de gens qui
sont pour l'ouverture à l'aide d'active
à mourir il y a des gens qui sont
opposés à l'euthanasie d'autres qui sont
opposés au suicide assisté et en réalité
le socle de ceux qui sont pour l'aide
active à mourir
et le chiffre qui a été dit par ma par
ma camarade 40% qui sont pour
l'ouverture
l'ouverture complète et à l'euthanasie
et au succès d'assister donc les
chiffres sont à relativiser à expliquer
les citoyens qui se sont positionnés
contre l'ont fait pour des motifs très
divers
d'une part par ce que le modèle de
civilisation
qui consistait jusque là soigner coûte
que coûte à prendre soin du patient du
malade de la personne en souffrance
risque de changer pour un modèle vers
lequel on irait vers une médecine
libérale d'un libéralisme d'opinion
finalement chacun pourrait demander à la
carte ce qui l'arrangerait et ça nous
paraît inquiétant
par ailleurs
nous n'avons pas été convaincus par la
mise en place et l'explication des
garde-fous des commissions d'enquête qui
sont censées encadrer les processus de
tanasie ou de suicide assisté
et enfin nous nous avons considéré et je
pense à raison que le centre des débats
n'était pas sur le tanazi ou le suicide
assisté mais sur la question de
l'hôpital de sa gestion des soins
palliatifs et de l'accompagnement des
patients il y a beaucoup pas faire dans
ces domaines et les améliorations que
nous pourrions apporter à l'hôpital à sa
gestion aux soins sont un préalable à
tout autre discussion à mon avis